mais d'abord c'est chiffre que les états
majors des deux finalistes scrutent
depuis dimanche dernier les reports de
voies sont-ils figées notamment parmi
les électeurs de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
Samia de chir répond à la question
Étienne sans doute la clé du second tour
très partagez les électeurs de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon sont scrutés à la loupe dans
une consultation interne la France
insoumise à interroger sa base les
quelques 215 000 militants qui se sont
exprimés votre rond blanc à plus de 37%,
vient ensuite le vote Emmanuel Macron a
plus de 33% et un peu moins d'un tiers
s'abstiendrait l'option Marine Le Pen
n'était pas proposée c'est la différence
notable avec un sondage bien plus large
mené auprès des 7 millions 700 000
lecteurs de Jean-Luc Mélenchon 22%
visage de voter pour la candidate du
rassemblement national mais comme chez
les militants c'est le vote blanc ou
l'abstention qu'il l'emporte cette fois
à 41% suivi de près par l'option
Emmanuel Macron des tendances rester
jusqu'ici relativement stable mais qui
pourrait bien bouger d'ici dimanche à
force d'approcher de la date finalement
peut-être que certains électeurs se
diront quel sera la conséquence de mon
vote ou de mon nom vote à ce second tour
et c'est une c'est une caractéristique à
ne pas sous-estimer parce qu'en 2017 il
faut souvenir qu'en 2017 au lendemain du
premier tour on mesurait des rapports de
force de 60 40 en faveur d'Emmanuel
Macron et que Marine Le Pen a chuté dans
les tous derniers jours certes en partie
à cause de sa prestation ratée lors du
débat entre deux tours mais aussi parce
que ce fameux mur du second tour s'est
présenté et que les électeurs qui
étaient partis dans un d'une réponse
mini à ce dilemme finalement c'était
décidé à moins voter pour Marine Le Pen
ou à davantage appuyer Emmanuel Macron à
force de convoiter le réservoir
mélenchoniste Emmanuel Macron pourrait
en négliger d'autres celui des électeurs
de Valérie Pécresse dont un tiers
prévoit de s'abstenir un chiffre presque
identique dans l'électorat de Yannick
Jadot même si dans les deux cas leur
choix se porte majoritairement Emmanuel
Macron
prend pour argent comptant ou encore
pour acquis que l'électorat de du centre
droit et du centre gauche ne peut que se
rabattre vers lui là aussi c'est une
interrogation est-ce que cette électorat
va s'abstenir je pense en particulier du
côté du centre gauche plutôt que du côté
du centre droit au centre gauche dans
les électorats j'adore dans les
électorats Hidalgo et aussi beaucoup
d'hésitations d'après le dernier sondage
Ifop Emmanuel Macron et pour l'instant
donné gagnant du second tour avec 55%
des voix contre 45% pour ça arrive à
Marine Le Pen et on analyse ces jours
décisifs avec mes invités Joséphine star
on bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
responsable des études politiques et des
relations internationales du cercle de
réflexion cynopia jean-louisika bonsoir
responsabilités
de réflexion Terra Nova ou publié le
business de la haine internet la
démocratie et les réseaux sociaux livres
coécrit avec Henri Verdier publié chez
Kalman Levy j'accue également
François-Xavier Bourbon bonsoir grand au
service politique du Figaro votre livre
c'est Macron Le Pen le tango des
fossoyeurs écrit avec Charles sapin
publié aux éditions de l'archipel vous
avez mis dans le mille d'une certaine
façon on peut dire ça comme ça on y
reviendra évidemment Matthieu croissanto
bonsoir politique merci d'être là
Matthieu exceptionnellement un mardi et
vous serez là encore demain et c'est un
bonheur de vous avoir à mes côtés
évidemment alors on a vu les chiffres
d'un des instituts je vous propose le
tout dernier baromètre il est il date
d'il y a une heure à peine ipso sopra
Steria cette fois-ci
ipso c'est notre partenaire des soirées
électorales sur public Senna et LCP avec
un email Macron qui a 56 et demi Marine
Le Pen à 43 ans et demi donc là on est à
13 points d'écart cette c'est encore
plus que le sondage qu'on voyait à
l'instant dans le dans le sujet de de
Samia déchire Joséphine Sarron à qui
elle profite cette campagne de
d'entre-deux-tours un peu à Emmanuel
Macron si l'on en croit les sondages et
on garde notre prudence habituelle dans
cette émission en tout cas ce qui est
certain c'est que la dynamique pour
l'instant du second tour est en faveur
d'Emmanuel Macron mais il faut bien
regarder qu'on n'est pas du tout dans le
même cas de figure qu'en 2017 on avait
plus de 30 points d'écart entre Emmanuel
Macron et Marine Le Pen aujourd'hui on
vous dit 13 ce soir c'est 10 dans
d'autres sondages donc ça reste quand
même très serré et on sait que on l'a vu
dans votre reportage les
abstentionnistes ou les personnes qui
disent voter blanc vont être
déterminants pour l'issue du scrutin et
pour l'écart entre les deux candidats il
faut bien regarder que le débat de
demain va être déterminant pour un quart
presque des Français qui n'ont pas
encore fait leur choix alors est-ce que
ce sont des personnes qui hésitent entre
Emmanuel Macron et Marine Le Pen ou
entre un vote blanc une abstention et
l'un des deux candidats dans tous les
cas ce choix de ce car des Français sera
déterminant pour le résultat dimanche
prochain on y reviendra évidemment au
débat Jean-Loup musical la stratégie
d'Emmanuel Macron qui est assez voyante
les appels du pied répété électorale
écologiste soit celui de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon c'est peut-être voyant mais
est-ce que c'est efficace ça a une
certaine efficacité si on voit
effectivement
même du des intentions de vote de
l'électorat de l'électorat Mélenchon
notamment dans le sondage de dipsos dont
vous avez parlé puisque c'est un sondage
qu'on appelle un rolling et donc nous
avons des données presque tous les jours
et on voit quand même qu'il y a une
lente montée du vote Macron et une
légère baisse du vote blanc ou de
l'abstentionistes on va voir les
chiffres c'est 39 le dernier XO c'est un
dernier League c'est 39 tirages vers
Emmanuel Macron 16 vers Marine Le Pen et
45 vers l'absence en face ça veut dire
quand même que près d'un électeur sur
deux de Jean-Luc Mélenchon envisage le
vote blanc et ou l'abstention ce qui est
quand même beaucoup et je partage votre
point de vue
certains d'entre eux se détermineront au
dernier moment et sans doute quand même
que le débat va jouer un rôle dans dans
cette détermination maintenant les
appels du pied ne sont pas que du côté
d'Emmanuel Macron quand Madame Le Pen
renonce à l'interdiction du voile dans
l'espace public ou en tout cas hésite on
va dire ça
elle a dit elle a dit oui non
c'est aussi un clin d'oeil qu'elle
envoie à cet électorat mélanges en même
temps on les comprend tous les deux 22%
des suffrages c'est de loin le réservoir
de bulletins de vote le plus le plus
important donc il cherche tous les deux
à essayer de mobiliser cette électorat
Emmanuel Macron avec ce discours qu'il a
fait à propos de l'écologie à Marseille
et Marine Le Pen en adoucissant quand
même
son discours xénophobe
François-Xavier Bourbon la thèse de
votre livre c'est que finalement bon bah
Macron Emmanuel Macron et Marine Le Pen
ont tout fait pour jouer ce remake et
que les autres ont tout fait pour
l'empêcher et ils n'y ont pas ils n'ont
pas réussi donc simplement quand on
regarde rétrospectivement la campagne en
fait on voit que la tenaille Macron Le
Pen et extrêmement puissante il y a eu
trois tentatives de la desserrer une
première avec Eric Zemmour qui a essayé
de reste réinstaurer un clivage
droite-gauche très marqué très marqué à
droite ça a échouer et une deuxième
tentative avec Valérie Pécresse qui a
été la seule dans les enquêtes
d'opinions les sondages à approcher à un
moment Emmanuel Macron au second tour à
55 ans ça a pas ça a pas fonctionné non
plus et puis la dernière tentative
Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui a une très forte
dynamique sur la fin qui était en train
de se hisser vers le second tour mais
qui est qui a pas réussi à desserrer
cette tenaille c'est dire que derrière
Emmanuel Macron et Marine Le Pen il y a
des courants qui sont beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus fort qu'un mouvement
d'opinion autour de deux personnes on a
vraiment un clivage qui s'est installé
entre les pros européens eurosceptiques
de part et d'autre les conservateurs
progressistes enfin ce clivage qui avait
été identifié par Emmanuel Macron pour
bâtir sa stratégie de campagne en 2017
et donc il voulait que le second tour de
2022 le confirme et on y est c'est le
nouveau clivage français ce qu'on peut
dire ça oui mais c'est peut-être un peu
plus compliqué que ça on a quand même
des une population française ce qui est
globalement déçu du
d'Emmanuel Macron mais qui était déçu de
tous les quinquennat précédents
rappelons que ça fait quand même un
moment qu'on n'a pas eu de président
reconduit pour un second mandat donc en
tout cas président qui avait
effectivement le pouvoir parce que
c'était des présidents de cohabitation
et la difficulté c'est que les gens
n'ont plus confiance véritablement ni
dans Emmanuel Macron ni dans une vision
anti-système qui serait celle de Marine
Le Pen ou de Jean-Luc Mélenchon dans une
autre mesure et qu'il cherche cet entre
deux alors c'est entre deux en 2017
c'était Emmanuel Macron qui semblait
l'incarner le en même temps aujourd'hui
plus tout à fait puisque Emmanuel Macron
défend une ligne très libérale très
progressiste très européistes et Marine
Le Pen joue effectivement la carte
beaucoup plus conservatrice et moins
européiste mais quand même elle modère
davantage ses propos elle est beaucoup
moins extrême qu'elle ne l'était en 2017
ce qui lui permet de récupérer une
partie d'un électorat qui aurait a été
qui n'aurait jamais pu être séduit par
le discours d'une de Marine Le Pen de
2017 Mathieu on a montré deux sondages
là ce soir il y en a il faut qu'il donne
10 points d'écart et puis ipso sont des
on est à 13 points d'écart est-ce que ça
peut avoir un effet démobilisateur on a
vu quand même en regardant avant le
premier tour les il y a beaucoup
d'électeurs qui se sont décidés aussi
avec le triple vote utile en fonction de
des sondages donc il faut pas
sous-estimer l'effet de ces sondages sur
une partie de l'électorale qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez d'autant que aime
beaucoup de détecteurs sont pas motivés
par cette affiche on est passé quand
même de dégagisme en 2017 à une forme de
désintérêt ensuite pour la politique et
aujourd'hui une forme de dissidence
comme si certains Français décidaient de
ne plus participer au débat démocratique
ou à l'exercice de leur responsabilité
républicaine et ça c'est très dangereux
parce que le vote utile vous l'avez dit
pour le premier tour on affiche sa
préférence ou on crie sa colère ou on
adhère un projet c'est vrai qu'il y a eu
un réflexe de votre utile et la des
sondages dans la dernière semaine a
constitué un gros pôle extrême droite un
gros pot la gauche et un gros pôle
Centris en gros qui aggloméré tout ce
qui restait tous ceux qui ne voulaient
ni l'extrême droite l'extrême gauche qui
était exactement François Xavier le pari
d'Emmanuel Macron en 2017 c'est ce le
c'est ce paysage qu'il voulait qu'il
souhaitait aujourd'hui c'est vrai que
les bons sondages en faveur d'Emmanuel
Macron parce que moi je ne suis pas
certain qu'on puisse dire qu'il y ait
une dynamique de campagne observée par
les Français qui comptabilisent les
gestes ici ou là la plupart des Français
ne suivent pas la campagne comme on la
suit nous ils sont bien incapables de
dire qu'elles déplacement a fait
Emmanuel Macron ou ce qu'a fait Marine
Le Pen sans doute ont-ils retenu de la
campagne Macron quand on les interroge
c'est la fameuse retraite à 65 ans donc
peut-être ont-ils entendu qu'il était un
peu revenu dessus quant à Marine Le Pen
elle a fait plus parler d'elle malgré
elle d'une certaine façon que
positivement donc je suis pas certain
que ça joue beaucoup cette
entre-deux-tours en revanche ce qui se
joue c'est que le second tour c'est
toujours une question de crédibilité et
à qui on confie les clés et là
mécaniquement je pense que l'écart ils
se creusent là parce que Marine Le Pen
apparaît quand même inexpérimenté et et
mal entouré pas assez au sens de pas
assez entouré pas assez isolé et c'est
vrai que c'est bon chiffre dont vous
parliez vont au risque de démobiliser
toute une partie des électeurs qui
allait distille sur les réseaux sociaux
avec une pince à linge comme on disait
autrefois du vote pour Jacques Chirac
contre Jean-Marie Le Pen ou voilà qui
allait à
contre contre-pied je ne sais pas si
c'est très français
en tout cas contre leur
gris la volonté ce second tour peut-il
se transformer un référendum anti-macron
c'est peut-être pour contrer cette idée
que le président sortant disait ceci
samedi à Marseille écoutez
le 24 avril
c'est un référendum pour ou contre
l'Union européenne
le 24 avril
c'est un référendum pour ou contre
l'écologie
le 24 avril c'est un référendum pour ou
contre notre jeunesse
contre notre République et cette
nouvelle époque
oui le 24 avril peut-être le point de
départ d'une nouvelle époque française
et européenne celle de l'esp
salut climat celle de l'ambition
Jean-Louis quand même un paradoxe
Emmanuel Macron il termine ce mandat à
40% de popularité et en même temps il a
il agit comme un repoussoir auprès de
beaucoup de Français c'est assez vous
avez parfaitement raison c'est quelque
chose d'assez nouveau parce que cette
hostilité cette détestation même
d'Emmanuel Macron n'est pas une
détestation politique c'est une
détestation personnelle et c'est
d'ailleurs la grande différence avec par
exemple la détestation de certains
Français à l'égard de Nicolas Sarkozy il
détestait Sarkozy politiquement mais ce
qui est nouveau dans le cas Macron si
vous voulez c'est cette espèce de
détestation de la personne Macron le
banquier le président des riches
l'arrogance celui qui nous méprise etc
etc et donc ça effectivement c'est ce
qui explique d'ailleurs la difficulté
d'un certain nombre d'électeurs de
gauche
à voter pour lui au second tour et c'est
s'explique aussi le fait que Marine Le
Pen essaie de transformer ce deuxième
tour en un référendum anti Macron et
d'ailleurs je pense que toute sa
stratégie lors du débat de mercredi soir
tournera autour de ça François-Xavier
bon c'est clairement une stratégie du
camp Le Pen ça le référendum anti Macron
essayer d'installer ça oui c'est
frappant cette séquence là de cette
campagne d'entre deux tours parce qu'en
fait il y a une répétition générale de
cette de cet épisode c'était les
élections européennes de 2019 où Marine
Le Pen sur ses affiches de campagne a
écrit voté contre Macron et Emmanuel
Macron descend dans le dans l'arène
électorale à la toute fin de la campagne
et dénonce la lèpre populiste et ça se
termine avec Marine Le Pen en tête d'une
courte avance devant Emmanuel Macron
mais ce ce bras de fer il s'est déjà
joué à l'occasion des européennes une
différence presse qui avait été très
fort a été fort a été fort derrière là
on est vraiment en face à face donc
c'est c'est un contrat sur la
détestation il y a effectivement quelque
chose de frappant dans le dernier
meeting de à Strasbourg quand Emmanuel
Macron est en meeting à Strasbourg il y
a des perturbations dans le dans la
foule en général les gens qui viennent
perturber les meetings et de porter un
message là qu'il y avait il y avait un
peu de tout il y avait des manifestants
antillais SF il y avait de l'extrême
gauche il y avait de l'extrême droite et
même des royalistes et des anarchistes
donc la contestation vient vraiment de
de partout sans doute peut-être aussi
parce que Emmanuel Macron a tout cassé
il a mis le paysage politique à terre et
les gens savent plus où ils habitent
avant c'était ça pour voter à droite on
voter à gauche on s'y retrouver
facilement là le le paysage est en
construction et sans doute que pas les
une partie des Français n'arrivent pas à
s'y retrouver
Marine Le Pen qui puisqu'on est dans la
stratégie du camp Le Pen à la publier
une nouvelle vidéo aujourd'hui que nos
confrères de BFM TV ont diffusé elle
affirme que le président sortant n'a que
la peur comme stratégie écoutez
la peur c'est en effet le seul argument
qui reste à l'actuel président de la
République pour tenter de se maintenir à
tout prix prolongeant ainsi un mandat au
cours duquel nos libertés auront
grandement souffert la peur la peur
comme ressort paralysant comme moyen
désespéré de vous empêcher de réfléchir
et de choisir en votre âme et conscience
notre la petite musique apaisante en
fond sonore comment vous analysez ce
clip Joséphine Staron c'est bon c'est un
clip antifont républicain ça c'est un
peu basique comme analyse mais si on
veut un peu plus loin c'est de voir que
c'est exactement la rhétorique aussi
d'Emmanuel Macron et de tous ceux qui
sont anti-Marine
joue la peur pour vous pour vous
convaincre et elle lui rétent la même
chose c'est intéressant de voir que
finalement les deux candidats emploient
la même rhétorique et la même manière de
s'adresser à l'électorat français
maintenant ce qui est intéressant pour
revenir sur la détestation d'Emmanuel
Macron on disait que d'aller se jouer
sur la crédibilité ça on le verra demain
soir lors du débat est-ce que Marine Le
Pen paraîtra plus crédible qu'elle ne
l'a été en 2017 les Français en tout cas
ont vu un Emmanuel Macron pendant 5 ans
gouverner le pays et donc peuvent
aujourd'hui le juger peuvent le juger
sur ses actes sur ses faits sur 5 ans de
mandats 50 crises aussi il faut pas
l'oublier et c'est là-dessus que Marine
Le Pen va axer le débat ça va être sa
stratégie de dresser le bilan d'Emmanuel
Macron et de le mettre face à ce bilan
ce bilan que les Français contestent en
grande partie et elle va aussi lui
opposer l'argument du quoi qu'il en
coûte que pour montrer qu'il n'est pas
plus crédible qu'elle économiquement et
c'est là où les réponses du chiffrage
très intéressantes
il est tout prêt quand un cale même et
ça va être dans une minute parce que
j'aurais donné encore la parole à
Jean-Louis Sika vous vous publiez
signer pour Terra Nova une tribune le
titre c'est comment Marine Le Pen
prépare son coup d'État oui et vous vous
placez dans dans la configuration d'une
victoire de Marine Le Pen je dis que si
elle gagne elle fera un coup d'état
institutionnel et ça je suis pas le seul
à le dire beaucoup de spécialistes de
droit constitutionnels le disent tout
simplement parce que le référendum
qu'elle propose sur l'immigration est un
référendum purement et simplement
illégal alors ce que d'ailleurs je
voudrais revenir sur un point qui a été
évoqué dans ce débat on dit que Marine
Le Pen a adouci son discours oui en
termes d'image à la télévision mais
quand on rentre dans le détail de son
programme c'est un programme d'extrême
droite extrêmement dur et notamment ce
référendum sur l'immigration qui est
extrêmement intéressant on se rend
compte que c'est un référendum où elle
va en quelque sorte changer la
constitution sans respecter l'article 89
de la Constitution c'est-à-dire sans
consultation du Sénat et de l'Assemblée
nationale et elle dit également elle l'a
dit sur France Inter elle dit également
que même si le Conseil constitutionnel
et le Conseil d'État donne un avis
favorable à cette à ce référendum et
bien elle le fera quand même et donc
c'est ça le coup d'État parce que si
jamais vous ne respectez pas les
institutions et bien vous sortez du
droit et cette cette décision qu'elle
annonce c'est la sortie de l'État de
droit et elle veut le faire dès son
élection donc si vous voulez les mois
qui viennent si elle est élue risquait
d'être des mois extrêmement
violents aussi bien dans la rue que dans
le débat politique parce que justement
elle a l'intention de s'asseoir sur la
Constitution de la Cinquième République
l'argument qu'elle avance c'est que le
général de Gaulle l'a fait avant elle ce
qui est vrai 62 69 62 oui enfin 60
mais il faut rappeler que on a été à
deux doigts d'une crise majeure en 1962
le président du Sénat on est ici sur
Public Sénat Gaston baderville avait
parlé de forfaiture et avait réclamé non
seulement la démission du général de
Gaulle mais son incarcération dans ce
fameux discours donc si vous voulez dire
que tout ça va se passer comme dans un
déjeuner de campagne est un mensonge et
honte alors on va parler du chiffrage et
ça va nous amener à développer vous avez
les uns les autres argumentés sur le
débat et on va y passer évidemment un
peu de temps quand tu as un calmé c'est
l'heure comme prévu comme promis
grossoir Quentin le chiffrage des
programmes évidemment c'est un enjeu clé
de cette campagne de d'entre-deux tours
notamment pour Marine Le Pen il s'agit
de démontrer le sérieux de sa
candidature voilà un chiffrage du
sérieux peut-être que c'est ce qu'il y
avait aussi manqué en 2017 donc elle a
pris ce sujet abrahaltor très tôt dans
la campagne et l'organiser une
conférence de presse sur ce chiffrage le
23 mars dernier à la clé déjà un propos
liminaire de 14 minutes pour expliquer
les principales clés de voûte de ce
programme économique elle parle de 38
milliards de dépenses parfaitement
équilibré avec 68 milliards d'euros de
recettes une grande part des économies
réalisées se fait grâce aux mesures sur
l'immigration et la lutte contre la
fraude elle s'est aussi des effets
positifs directement liés à certaines de
ces réformes comme celle des retraites
en écoutant un extrait
va entraîner d'une part un regain de
consommation et donc des nouvelles
recettes de TVA et d'autre part une
baisse du chômage des seniors et un
regain de cotisations des jeunes étant
donné que comme la Cour des comptes la
souligner les changements sur l'âge des
départs à la retraite ont un impact
important sur les comptes sociaux nous
avons chiffré l'impact de ces mesures à
11,4 milliards d'euros de réussite alors
certains instituts ont tenté de refaire
ces démonstrations sur le chiffrage à
l'image de l'Institut montagne qu'il a
fait pour les 12 candidats à l'élection
présidentielle de 1 du 1er tour alors le
moins que l'on puisse dire c'est qu'il y
a un écart certains parleront d'un fossé
abyssal entre les prévisions de Marine
Le Pen et le chiffrage de l'Institut
prenant par exemple un toutes les
promesses par exemple celles sur les
dépenses il chiffre est ainsi 26,5
milliards pour la retraite à 60 ans 12,6
pour le prêt à taux zéro pour l'accès à
la propriété voilà il chiffre aussi les
baisses de cotisation patronales ou
encore les baisses de TVA sur l'énergie
et arrive à ce montant total que l'on
voit
119,6 milliards et non et bien 68 comme
dit Marine Le Pen quant aux recettes et
autres économies donc qui se fait pour
une large partie sur l'immigration ils
arrivent qu'aux chiffres très maigre de
17,8 milliards c'est donc dans ce calcul
que l'on voit ici à l'antenne donc on
voit cette énorme marge c'était énorme
écart ce delta entre le chiffrage de la
candidate et celui de l'Institut de
recherche à la clé le signe tank parle
d'une dépense de l'État nette de plus de
100 milliards d'euros par an et c'est à
dire une trajectoire d'insoutenabilité
forte je cite qui mettrait en risque je
cite encore la souveraineté de la France
alors voilà pour Marine Le Pen que dire
du chiffrage d'Emmanuel Macron Quentin
davantage crédible mais très optimiste
quand même oui c'est ça que l'on peut
retenir effectivement de ce même
institué alors le programme
effectivement jugé plus sérieux
rigoureux que celui de Marine Le Pen par
les économistes mais il n'est pas sans
faiblesse dit-il déjà notons que le
financement des mesures il est très peu
évoqué sur les 24 pages du pamphlet du
du programme on l'a pas trouvé c'est pas
donné de façon très nette et précise
alors il a bien évoqué dans les grandes
lignes lors de cette grande conférence
de presse qu'il a donné le 17 mars
dernier c'était vraiment la grande
conférence de presse qui a duré très
longtemps de nombreuses heures et là
encore il prend la parole pendant une
heure et il en parle pas c'est
uniquement une fois qu'il est interrogé
par derrière la toute première journée
qui prend la parole sur la qu'il donne
un peu d'explication une réponse sur
trois minutes on en a gardé 30 secondes
écouter le résumé le projet que je viens
de vous présenter
représente un effort budgétaire à
hauteur de 50 milliards d'euros par an
d'ici 2027 de quelle manière on financé
50 milliards d'une part en dégageant par
les réformes 15 milliards d'euros
activités croissante j'ai affecte les
gains par la réforme des retraites et
les gains sur la réforme chômage 15
milliards sont financés par les réformes
de fonds et les simplifications et 20
milliards en ayant une trajectoire de
réduction par rapport au temps d'un ciel
des coûts de fonctionnement sur
l'ensemble des collectivités publiques
voilà on comprend le président le
candidate sur la réforme de l'État dans
un contexte qui l'espère de plein emploi
avec une croissance forte il mise aussi
sur la lutte contre la fraude et encore
l'effort des collectivités territoriales
les prévisions que l'on peut dire
optimistes dans le contexte économique
mondial sur la crise en Ukraine et
également la crise du covid vient tendre
comme cela à l'économie si on regarde à
nouveau la synthèse de l'Institut
Montaigne alors entre promesses pour
l'environnement ou encore pour
l'éducation les suppressions d'impôts ou
encore les mesures en faveur du pouvoir
d'achat tout cela est chiffré à 57,2
milliards d'euros par an et côté recette
concrète on note que la réforme des
retraites les économies des
collectivités locales cela fait un
maigre 12,7 milliards doit un écart là
encore mais de 44 milliards entre les
dépenses et les recettes une énorme
différence qui s'explique selon le signe
tank par les perspectives de la réforme
de l'état de son fonctionnement et de
lutte contre les Ford dans la
matérialisation n'est pas acquise écrit
le signe tank et d'ailleurs dans ce
chiffrage et bien ce qui interroge aussi
c'est le fait que Emmanuel Macron ne
veut pas sortir de la perspective d'une
baisse des déficits sous la barre de 3%
d'ici à la fin de son prochain
quinquennat s'il est réélu merci Quentin
pour toutes ces explications Joséphine
starre on sait c'est peut-être le
principal angle d'attaque de d'Emmanuel
Macron demain soir face à Marine Le Pen
ce chiffrage ou ou peut-être plus
globalement le programme économique de
la candidate du le programme économique
oui mais le chiffrage ça va être tout
aussi compliqué pour Emmanuel Macron que
pour Marine Le Pen parce
qu'effectivement l'un comme l'autre ont
une vision très optimiste de l'économie
française or on a on est dans un état
d'endettement public rarement atteint
les comptes publics sont été on va dire
asséchés avec la crise sanitaire et les
effets de la guerre en Ukraine
aujourd'hui
celui qui sera président de toute
manière n'aura pas énormément de marge
de manœuvre économiques et ça les
Français en ont bien conscience donc le
débat demain va se porter sur le pouvoir
d'achat c'est d'ailleurs je crois le
premier thème qui a été
et puis c'est de loin encore la
préoccupation principale des Françaises
très loin quand on regarde les études
c'est 20 points devant le deuxième thème
avait pris un certain avantage parce que
dès le début de sa campagne elle a tout
misé sur la thématique du pouvoir
d'achat surtout je pense pas que le
chiffre je suis pas certain que le
chiffrage soit un enjeu du débat d'abord
parce que les Français veulent jamais
pour un programme de finances publiques
ils s'en fiche complètement l'idée que
les comptes soient à l'équilibre ou que
l'orthodoxie budgétaire c'est pas
quelque chose qui parle les candidats
qui avaient essayé de se fait avenir
là-dessus je pense à François Fillon
avait commencé à décrocher dans les
sondages avant même son scandale parce
que l'idée de faire des économies par
milliards ne parlent pas forcément en
français c'est si vous parlez de baisse
d'impôts oui ça leur parle si vous
parlez le reste équilibrer les comptes
c'est pas grand chose et deuxièmement
parce qu'on sort en plus d'un contexte
ou l'argent n'a plus de signification
les sommes en jeu n'ont plus significats
le quoi qu'il en coûte à montrer que
quand il y avait besoin d'argent on
pouvait en trouver que c'était pas si
grave de de d'être au niveau français au
niveau européen 200 DT et donc du coup
voilà les grandes masses on sait déjà
que ça dépasse quand même l'entendement
quand on raisonne à l'échelle de 15
milliards 50 milliards 100 milliards
donc je suis pas persuadé que ce sera
là-dessus la crédibilité avant et ce
jouet peut-être sur les critères
économiques je pense qu'à ce jour a plus
sur la scène internationale ou sur la
gestion de la pandémie par exemple
qu'est-ce que vous auriez fait qu'est-ce
que j'ai fait voilà ou sur scène
internationale ça ça ce sont des
thématiques qui peuvent mettre en jeu la
crédibilité mais le chiffrage et sur la
Russie je pense que elle sera en
position défensive on voit tous les
soutiens d'Emmanuel Macron depuis
plusieurs jours depuis le début de la
campagne de Tours c'est vraiment dans
chaque prise de parole bien sûr il y a
cet axe bien sûr qui est travaillé il
faut reconnaître et on peut le
comprendre sa volonté de faire une
alliance avec la Russie malgré la guerre
quand même assez étonnante et ce sera
d'ailleurs l'un des thèmes qu'on
abordera dans notre second débat tout à
l'heure parce qu'on a quatre
correspondants étrangers qui vont réagir
à la campagne française François-Xavier
Bourbon quelques coulisses de
préparation de ce débat comment comment
Marine Le Pen pour commencer ce prêt par
tel déjà il fait l'inverse de ce qu'elle
avait fait il y a il y a 5 ans
c'est-à-dire que elle avait un programme
assez chargé elle était arrivée fatiguée
au débat là elle a bloqué deux jours
deux jours avant le débat pour
travailler ce reposer et travailler et
travailler ces thèmes il y a un enjeu
important pour Marine Le Pen puisque le
débat de dit à 5 ans elle était tombé
dans un piège que lui avait tendu
l'équipe Macron de deux trois jours
avant il avait fait circuler le bruit si
elle était trop agressive sur le plateau
elle se lèverait Emmanuel Macron se
lèverait et quittait la table comme
Marine Le Pen avait du retard dans les
dans les sondages énormément de retard
autour de autour d'elle on lui dit il
faut jouer l'agressivité il faut le
pousser à partir parce que ça s'est
jamais vu dans un débat et donc il faut
lui faire perdre ses nerfs donc d'où
l'attitude extrêmement agressive qu'elle
a dans les deux premières minutes et
Emmanuel Macron ne réagit pas et en fait
elle comprend très vite qu'elle est
tombée dans le dans le piège que la
qualité victime d'une intox et elle doit
tenir le reste du débat sur la ligne la
ligne stratégique et s'était fixée qui
était d'être agressif donc elle perd
elle perd pied il y a cet enjeu là pour
elle qui est de se rattraper déjà de
cette action de cette intox de ce fait
avoir en revanche quoi aussi de toute
façon et sur les finances publiques il y
a peut-être juste un enjeu pour elle qui
est justement un enjeu de crédibilité
parce qu'elle était apparue à l'époque
comme un peu à côté de la plaque là avec
le chiffrage des programmes c'est le
seul peut-être la seule chose qui sera
intéressante à regarder dans la
discussion entre Emmanuel Macron et
Marine Le Pen c'est
lorsqu'elle arrive à défendre ses
positions et être crédible dessus et
quand on voit l'écart entre le coiffeur
qu'on a présenté là
demain plutôt Emmanuel Macron ah oui oui
je pense que Manuel Macron a beaucoup à
perdre et que elle elle a beaucoup pas
gagné parce que le critère que l'on va
utiliser pour juger de sa prestation
c'est la prestation de 2017 et donc
c'est difficile d'imaginer qu'elle fasse
moins bien quand même et donc bien
évidemment elle elle va elle elle va
gagner en crédibilité et peut-être même
qu'elle va réussir un peu à effacer ce
stigmate qu'a représenté cette
prestation complètement ratée de 2017
pour Emmanuel Macron le risque pour lui
c'est là c'est là c'est le dérapage vous
savez que il est quand même assez
familier de ces phrases à
l'emporte-pièce qui donne le sentiment
aux Français que vraiment vraiment il
est méprisant et arrogant etc donc il
faut vraiment qu'il essaye d'éviter ce
genre de ce genre de dérapage verbal
parce que ça ça peut lui coûter des voix
ça de lui coûter pas mal de voix donc ce
débat il est complètement déséquilibré
l'une à tout à gagner et l'autre a tout
à perdre c'est quand même une équation
compliquée je suis de savon pour pour
Marine Le Pen parce que on l'a vu elle
est allée entre 10 et 13 points à
rattraper et dans sa stratégie il faut
pas qu'elle soit agressive puisqu'elle
est dans une stratégie d'apaisement mais
il faut quand même qu'elle soit
offensive parce qu'elle a du retard donc
c'est pas si simple c'est pas si simple
ce qui est certain c'est que la
stratégie qui serait la bonne pour elle
c'est de rester extrêmement calme
extrêmement posée tout l'inverse de 2017
et ce qui pourrait lui faire gagner des
points c'est si Emmanuel Macron
s'emportait et au contraire lui devenait
agressif mais vous disiez tout à l'heure
vous disiez tout à l'heure qu'il fallait
qu'elle aille sur le bilan d'Emmanuel
Macron faut aussi qu'elle présente sa
vision ou son programme quoi c'est
qu'elle passe pas tout le temps à parler
de l'autre vous voyez ce que je veux
dire ça va être un enjeu pour elle mais
là elle a une chance qu'elle n'avait pas
en 2017 c'est qu'elle se elle va se
débattre avec quelqu'un qui a déjà
exercé le pouvoir et elle va pouvoir je
vais dire voilà tirer les billes de ce
quinquennat et lui opposer tout ce
qu'elle considère comme étant de
mauvaises réforme de mauvaise idée une
mauvaise gestion que ce soit sur la
crise sanitaire ou autre là où elle aura
probablement du mal et je rejoins ce qui
a été dit c'est sur la guerre en Ukraine
ou Emmanuel Macron va probablement jouer
l'international comme voilà un de ses
axes forts et où elle va se retrouver un
petit peu en difficulté ça c'est très
probable de toute façon dans un débat
comme celui-là on n'est jamais que sur
la défensive on est rarement dans
l'exposition de son projet parce que
chaque candidat profite au lieu de dire
mais moi j'ai envie de faire ça et je
pense que ça serait bon pour la France
on est toujours sur bidon votre projet
voilà donc c'est c'est toujours un jeu
contre un jeu de un jeu d'attaque elle
elle va devoir essayer de parler à tous
les déçus de Macron il y a tous ceux on
en parlait tout à l'heure cette forme de
détestation personnelle qui tient à sa
personnalité la forme d'exercice du
pouvoir qui qui l'a fait pendant pendant
5 ans et puis tous ceux qui ont eu le
sentiment de se faire avoir au fond et
ils sont nombreux à droite à gauche
avoir pris un temps même de même avec
distance et Madame Macron pour une sorte
d'enfant prodige de la politique qui
réussissait à se faire élire là avec une
équation personne n'avait jamais réussi
donc peut-être qu'il lui en veulent un
peu pour ça et puis surtout des
électeurs de gauche qui devaient apporté
leur voix et qui se réalise que ils en
ont pas pour leur pour leur argent des
électeurs de droite qui leur avait
apporté leur voix même chose et qui
réalise qu'il a atomisé la droite bref
il y a beaucoup de gens qui ont dû
ressentiment soit l'égard de la
politique soit les gars de la
personnalité soit pour les conséquences
de cette recomposition du paysage alors
justement les électeurs de droite on va
en parler tout de suite avec ce soutien
reçu par Emmanuel Macron aujourd'hui
soutien de Claude Chirac et de son mari
Frédéric salabaru qui était l'ancien
secrétaire général de l'Elysée sous
Jacques Chirac ils ont appelé et je les
cite à ce que pas une voix ne manque à
Emmanuel Macron face à Marine Le Pen
faisant dans leur communiquer AFP
référence au combat de l'ancien
président contre l'extrémisme et
notamment à ce discours on est le 11
mars 2007 Jacques Chirac annonce sans
surprise qu'il ne se représente pas et
s'adresse aux Français
ne composez jamais avec l'extrémisme le
racisme l'antisémitisme ou le rejet de
l'autre
le vrai combat de la France le beau
combat de la France
c'est celui de l'unité c'est celui de la
cohésion
oui nos valeurs ont un sens oui la
France est riche de sa diversité oui
l'honneur de la politique c'est d'agir
d'abord pour l'égalité des chances
François-Xavier bourmet est-ce que ce
message qui date quand même d'il y a 15
ans un pèse pèse encore sur une partie
de la famille politique de évidemment et
on en a une illustration pendant la
campagne présidentielle Éric Zemmour a
essayé de lever ce de briser cette digue
il y avait il a pas réussi c'est la
digue qui a été érigée par Jacques
Chirac dans son discours quand il quitte
l'Élysée tient jusqu'à présent quelques
transferts mais à la marge et ce
discours là il fonctionne toujours c'est
ce qui explique en tout cas l'échec
d'Éric Zemmour a réunifié brisé la digue
et réunifier les familles de loi enfin
faire l'alliance entre LR et le RM mais
Jean-Louis il y a un troisième tour dont
on va commencer à en parler même si on
va avoir le temps après après cette
présentiel c'est évidemment les
législatives ou là il y a des
recompositions qui vont être
intéressantes à suivre ça va être
extrêmement intéressant mais pour le
moment c'est vraiment la bouteille à
l'encre c'est-à-dire qu'on est personne
n'est capable de dire ne serait-ce que
quel sera l'offre politique par exemple
est-ce que l'extrême droite arrivera uni
ou diviser dans les circonscriptions que
vont faire les candidats de gauche vous
avez vu que
les les écologistes font des appels du
pied à la France insoumise mais que la
France insoumise a mis son veto à la
présence des socialistes dans les dans
les négociations donc est-ce qu'il y
aura plusieurs candidats de gauche s'il
y a plusieurs candidats de gauche ça
risque d'être une pérézina pour la
gauche parce que la règle des 12 et demi
pour cent je vais pas rentrer dans les
détails parce que c'est assez technique
mais enfin grosso modo il n'y aura
jamais plus que deux candidats au second
tour des législatives et si jamais il y
a plusieurs candidats de gauche au
premier tour la probabilité qu'il y ait
un candidat de gauche présent au second
tour et très faible et là on touche
vraiment au financement des partis on
touche au financement des partis
politiques c'est le nombre de voix que
l'on fait dans 50 circonscriptions c'est
une c'est une alors il faut reconnaître
que les règles du jeu de ces élections
législatives c'est un véritable piège
pour les partis parce que vous avez la
règle des 12 et demi pour cent il faut
faire il faut faire 12,5 % des inscrits
pour être présent au second tour 12 et
10% des inscrits quand vous avez 50%
abstention ça veut dire qu'il faut que
vous fassiez 25% des exprimés donc vous
voyez bien à quel point c'est compliqué
d'être présent au second tour mais de
l'autre côté il faut vous présentiez des
candidats le plus possible dans toutes
les circonscriptions parce que vous vous
touchez de l'argent en tant que parti
politique
au nombre de gens qui ont voté pour vous
et en plus il faut que vous ayez des
candidats dans au moins 50
circonscriptions donc d'un côté vous
avez une règle qui vous incite à vous
unir et de l'autre côté vous avez une
règle qui vous incite à vous désunir et
donc cette élection pour le moment ça va
être extrêmement compliqué je pense que
beaucoup de choses vont se jouer aussi
en fonction du résultat du second tour
de la présidentielle si Marine Le Pen
fait un bon score ou un moins bon score
et beaucoup de choses vont se jouer sur
la capacité par exemple de LR a résister
aux forces centrifuges entre ceux qui
vont plutôt vouloir aller vers la droite
de la droite et ceux qui vont plutôt
comme Nicolas Sarkozy vouloir trouver un
terrain d'entente et de gouvernance avec
Emmanuel Macron la déclaration de
Sarkozy on parle on parle de la
déclaration des chiracs et la
déclaration de Sarkozy est également
extrêmement importante parce que ce
qu'il propose des facto c'est une
alliance entre la droite et la
République en marche mais qui est pas
reçu forcément favorablement par tous
les cadres c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire non mais le problème
on est d'accord et peut-être et
peut-être pas les